you got an opportunity your your mentor
disappears for long stretches good let
him go take a long lunch boss I got it
oh you want to assign me these menial
tasks well eventually he's going to take
all these breaks then he's gonna have
you do the the more meaningful work so
that's fine
um you you can do better work than him
good that's gonna be fine that's going
to show through eventually he's
well-connected up the chain of command
beautiful beautiful because if you can
now build a relationship with him
you're going to be well connected to and
that's going to be the hardest part
right the heart that's me it's gonna be
hard to do and it's especially hard to
do because your attitude right now is
negative right your attitude right now
is negative it's a little ego kicking in
I can do better than him jeez I'm
underutilized
he's his he does things or I he's making
me do things beneath my capabilities
those were all just ego it's fine we
egos good egos got a lot of positives
through it it's what's driving you to
want to do better so it's okay but
you're gonna have to overcome that in
this scenario in order to build a
relationship with this guy man I built
relationships with guys that I hated you
know I mean because guess what does that
make me to face no you know what it's my
job I'm a professional yeah I am a
professional I guarantee you you come
and work with me
you will see I am a professional and yet
I will build relationships so not yet
but so that means my job and my
professionalism is more important than
my ego and my and my my criticality of
other people right I'm not looking down
on him going on so because what I want
to do is build a good relationship so
when we build that good relationship
with him now he's if he's well connected
with the folks up top they're like oh
what's up with Billy all Billy is good
to go man he's doing a great job now
what if you're like with the thing that
the other two what you gotta be careful
of
what you don't want to do is create an
antagonistic relationship aluminium and
that includes threatening him with your
work ethic threatening him with your
performance level threatening him with
your skills so you almost have to
throttle back just a little bit enough
that he's not threatened now the other
thing you can do instead of throttling
back is what you do is you give him the
credit but credit are you getting the
credit and you're good and now he's like
a pump
well he's not looking you become you
build the relationship that's what we
want to do we want to build a
relationship and we want to put your ego
in check
do the little menial tasks learn as much
as you can and let me tell you all this
is temporary you will rise top if you do
it right you will rise the top if you
screw it up you will never rise if you
create an anti antagonistic relationship
with him you will not promote you will
not if you do it right you will end up
above him in the chain of command it
will take time it will take swallowing
of pride but it will happen it might
take five years it might take seven
years it might take nine months I don't
know but that's what you have to do to
make it happen and have fun doing it if
you're going to go crazy every day if it
hurts you so bad I make a game out of it
I mean I'm going to make a total game
out of it where my goal is to build this
relationship with us yeah I'm gonna make
a game out of it we're gonna have fun
with it I'm not going to be angry when I
come home from work god I can't believe
I had to shake his hand no I'm gonna
come back like you know what Hey look
talk to my wife was a hey guess what he
actually bought me lunch today and we
were laughing about the football game I
don't even like football you know idiot
I'm gonna I'm gonna build that and I'm
gonna win and in the long run you're
guaranteed to win if you can play that
game
so again everyone thinks it's going to
be like he does not because I was the
military you just not meet the standards
what you do is you smash him and report
them up the chain of command oh that
good luck with that you have this guy's
well-connected and as relationships
later they're gonna go you and let's
shut up new guy
yeah because you're actually proving not
only you're actually proving when you do
this you're actually proving that you're
not a good leader and that you're put
your ego in check yeah you're proving
that you can't you're proved that you
can't work with some people we that guy
no joke oh he's all add Jocko can't work
with anybody yeah chunk was really good
as long as you working with you know his
team so what was that mean yeah means
you're confined for the rest of your
life of only working with your team you
know where is it it hey jock was good to
go he can work with anybody oh he worked
with Bill who's an egomaniac and he
worked with Mike who's a lazy bastard
guess what it doesn't matter where you
put chocolate he's gonna get it done
okay cool that's the attitude we want
people to have about us